this video is sponsored by our churro
welcome everybody it's me you know me
it's all about me
hey guys come back I'm kidding I brought
Marzia back because I need to do a
sponsorship first of all do you want to
try Xin Jie fuel
[Music]
let's get into the game our chair Oh
have you played this game before
no I looks cute it looks cute marzia so
the gist of this game is that you have
all these skills you can start playing
and I'll talk and you can combine them
for billions of different skills I don't
know if it's billions but basically you
start up simple level one as an archer
you should go upwards so intuitive you
don't even have to okay so you shoot
ball signing stuff so you want to be
able to walk okay so dodge arrows and
then when you want to shoot stun so for
a second oh my god he has angel so
beautiful Wow it's another warrior check
out our chair or guys hey hey what's up
you almost died woman mmm
yeah I like how they they set it up yeah
I haven't actually played that much I
kind of well you got a critical much are
your latesh you're dead you beat eight
percent of players that's a gamer moment
alright here we go it's pretty Pie's
turn I'll be trying no okay cuz you knew
what you and I think I do not know I'm a
gamer I just know what to do it
automatically come iets yeah mm-hmm how
was life for people I don't know what
you're doing everything is great yeah
nice nice the way it's nice real gamers
don't go outside kids would want HP
boost fire circle or sign air fire sir
odo okay so the more you play the more
you build on your abilities oh damn look
at the fire circles doing work
now it's instant tactical advantage
behind the wall and still do damage
aren't you impressed yeah what is this
nun de correr be laughing at me or for
me you found that angel okay fire choice
is a good choice this I you know you're
a gamer because you have gamer intuition
don't die all you got to do my thing
just don't die I bring you on this is
the most esteemed gaming channel of all
time and this is how you perform why do
I keep this in the other side
Thank You Martha yeah you were welcome
you were supposed to do my hair look now
I look like I told me you want me to do
your hair and you say just like it means
help again you get another chance
wait you see yeah but you have the
abilities I think yeah
no way you don't he walks into walls
okay fun trivia time I'm Archer oh where
do you think that comes from Archer plus
hero art arrow you can fly be our
postman is coming all right you keep
playing and the company happy is happy
Plus hobby here yeah with some more fun
tremors yes sure oh did you die okay so
we were I was correct it is a wrong
light which means it's procedurally
generated the way you play it
I know these are big words for you much
so the fights are unique basically lots
of content and form to more than 50
species of boxes and over 200 horrible
things how good I am a games I do promos
and I play at the same time 200 horrible
monsters you can play for a long time
without even getting bored well I'm not
bored yet I don't buy your Mars dude
where should I go dude I was gonna big
bowl don't walk into that
whoa you got the bolt use the bolt okay
okay yeah you might want to try and
finish one up there you go you got it
this is my girl
this is my gamer girl right here
everyone a round of applause
you beat sixteen percent of players a 16
percent of gamers you can all right what
do we got here you can upgrade give me
say how far the number one ranked is
honey whoa John wig
I'm about to show just how far the
number one gamers whoa see this this is
where we had really epic music - Dan it
even though the gameplay this isn't
magic poison poison touch okay so I hit
them once and they take damage look so
now I can just stay here in chill while
he dies that's cool
that's called gamer stranded that's very
brave of you what's that sarcasm and I
still got hit Jesus Christ I actually
want to perform
I just came oh I know all about that
my CSS holy crap you leave me with this
hell we do one that's fan alright we're
gonna practice all right what does he do
he shoots fireballs you shoot fireballs
like Angel Hitler mace I shoot the
dragon [ __ ] huh I'm disgusting oh come
on come on come on pause pause yeah good
good ah damn it I will actually play
this game on ironically I like it what
if I look at the poison doing that work
we we made the right choice with the
poison might say I'm listing that yes
good
no damage we're going five yeah and
Beyond no I messed up new best at least
we beat how many percent 100% of gamers
we beat a hundred percent of gamers we
beat a hundred percent of gamers all
right guys download our churro today
there's a link for iOS in the
description or click here to download
for Android
big thanks to Archer for sponsoring this
video but the biggest things to Margie I
see an Xbox or ship